all right notable receivers still
available some big names not just guys
who were star players several years ago
but guys who are currently star players
kenny goliday
leading the charge and uh some news as
it relates to gallaudet
the giants and bagels are interested
visited the bears makes me wonder if
they'd signed kenny galladay would they
strip the franchise tender from alan
robinson will be visiting the giants
today
uh look this is a guy who who wants to
strike it rich this is not the ideal
year to strike it rich and
he didn't play much last year the salary
cap's 25 million lower than it was
supposed to be
i just uh
i i don't know
where he's gonna land shireen and i
don't know if he's gonna get close to
what he probably would like to get which
is 20 million per year or north of it
yeah i don't know that's gonna happen
mike and this may be a one-year deal
after he played five games last year
with the hamstring and the hip injuries
he did think he was gonna strike it rich
and i thought the lions might franchise
tag him and they didn't and obviously
now he hasn't found the deal that he
thought he would find bengals have a
offer on the table but it obviously
wasn't good enough for him so
you know
what he's gonna get i don't know but i
would be
very
i would see it as very unlikely that he
gets a 20 million per day per year in a
long-term deal i just don't think that's
going to be possible this year he's
probably going to have to play on a
prove it deal and come back next year
and try to get that big deal after he
has a big year
and and that's what he should press for
one year deal one-year deal one-year
deal don't do something that gives the
team the ability to say hey yeah we'll
keep him around next year he was pretty
damn good and the market's going to
change and the salary cap's going to go
up get back to the market as often as
you can you just miss shuster we talked
today on pft live how there's no news on
juju i wrote something after the show no
news on juju then all of a sudden
there's news on juju the jets are
interested the steelers are interested
look this is a delicate spot for the
agents because juju smith schuster goes
into free agency with certain
expectations your biggest job as an
agent is to manage your clients
expectations i have a feeling he's not
happy with the interest or lack thereof
that he's gotten and if he'd gotten
anything
you know reasonably close to what he
wanted he'd have a deal by now and the
fact that the steelers are in it tells
me that that they know there's a chance
if he doesn't come close to getting what
he wants
they could get him back on maybe a
one-year deal for a reasonable salary
because they don't need him they know
him but they don't need him not with the
young receivers they have and their
ability to draft great receivers um i i
i'm surprised but not surprised that
they're in play but the fact they're in
play tells me that as a firm number two
receiver who had a chance in 2019 to
prove that he can be a number one and
failed he's not going to get the kind of
money that he believed maybe a year or
two ago he was going to get
and that was his best year mike was 2018
when he had a b on the other side of him
he won the team mvp award and it was the
beginning of the end of ab and
pittsburgh but pittsburgh may be his
best option because he knows the offense
he knows ben roethlisberger he had 831
yards and nine touchdowns for the
steelers it's a much better team than
the jets so if you're gonna go on a
short term deal and and put up big
numbers to get yourself a better deal
next off season next that's probably the
best place for him is pittsburgh because
he can have a bigger year i think than
with the jets who you don't even know
who your quarterback's going to be mike
yeah uh uh i i th this one fascinates me
and corey davis has already been paid by
the new york jets um and and you just
wonder how that depth chart shakes out
you need a true number one and
look corey davis would have had his
option picked up by the titans if he was
a true number one he'd still be on the
titans right now if he was a true number
one so i'd rather have a true number one
and a guy who can be number two than a
couple of number twos that i hope become
number one uh because if neither of
those guys commands double coverage all
the time
you basically have an extra defender
running around trying to stop what
you're doing offensively
um
so i i don't know if i asked you this
what do you think the ultimate landing
spot is let's do it for both guys what's
your gut tell you on kenny gallaudet
where do you think he's going to be
i think the giants are going to come up
with an offer that makes him happy
obviously the bengals did not or he
would have already signed there so i'm
going to go with the giants on this one
mike
i agree with you on the giants if not
the giants then the bengals maybe the
bengals spend a little bit more i'm
still concerned about the injuries from
last year although i tend to think that
it was a lack of willingness to play
while mildly injured without the
financial security that comes from a
long-term deal and that's not uncommon
that's not judgment of kenny holliday it
happens and there are plenty of agents
who will tell their clients don't you
play with that borderline health
condition because you don't have your
long-term security juju i got a weird
feeling
he's going to stay in the division i got
a weird feeling like someone like the
ravens is gonna see an opportunity and
swoop in and get him and if not the
ravens the bengals
oh that would be interesting one i'm
gonna go with the jets because they love
those x steelers right they they did it
with le'veon bell and and now they can
do it with neil o'donnell maybe
eventually it'll work neil o'donnell
yeah exactly keep rolling and dice and
maybe it'll work with one of them i'm
just going to go with the jets throw a
wing and throw it out there that the the
jets will make the best offer to him and
he lands with the jets
yeah i i just really am surprised that
that uh well i'm not surprised i'm not
surprised because we kind of saw this
coming
because he's not a number one
and he wants to break the bank and he
has every right to try
but you know the problem is if you don't
fully understand the market this is the
challenge going into free agency and i
think this is why the patriots signed so
many guys so quickly they managed to
convince the agents this is the best
your guy is going to do
and if you don't take it you're going to
have some tough questions to answer when
nothing better rolls around or nothing
even
close to being the same rolls around
once the door closes the first few days
you know the money dries up in free
agency and if you overshoot and you say
no
before the negotiating window opens and
the real negotiations happen and it's
clear that you want more than anyone's
going to pay by the time you've softened
your expectations
there's no money left to pay you what
you would have gotten right out of the
gates if you hadn't been aiming
ridiculously high for what it was you
were trying to make so uh i hope i hope
uh for the best for juju and i hope he
gets a one-year deal and gets back to
the market next year because i feel like
right now that's his best shot same with
gallaudet one year deal try it again
next year
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports